[Musique]
oui bienvenue à paradoxal
j'aimerais utiliser ma chronique pour
honorer une femme qui m'a beaucoup
inspiré beaucoup marqué aussi quand
j'étais sa collègue à faire votre Québec
je pense à France Robertson et Ninou de
m'acheter beaucoup trop tôt en 2018 à
cette époque-là elle était devenue la
directrice du Centre d'amitié de la
naudière dans les dernières semaines la
Ville de Joliette a voulu honorer
justement deux femmes extrêmement
importantes transaction d'un été une et
Jacqueline fait la chance était l'autre
elle a été la première à être élu
présidente de la Chambre de commerce du
Grand Joliette donc deux femmes qui sont
venues remplacer le nom de deux pairs
qui faisait partie de la Congrégation
des
des cars de saint-viateurs qui
malheureusement seront présentement au
cours au cœur d'un recours collectif
donc pour remplacer ces deux noms on a
choisi des noms de femmes clairement qui
ont été impliquées dans la version des
femmes et particulièrement dans le cas
de France
elle avait le dossier de la violence
contre les femmes les jeunes filles la
violence conjugale mais dans une
perspective autochtone vraiment au sein
même de tout ce qu'elle faisait et elle
est extrêmement appréciée par les gens
autour d'elle mais pourquoi je parle de
ce changement de nom de rue là c'est que
on parvait souvent à l'époque de la
transformation de la rue à murst pour
atteint de la toponymie autochtone des
changements des noms de rue qui on vient
honorer bien en honorant France
Robertson je pense qu'on la remet sur le
radar des personnes qui doivent faire
partie des histoires du Québec qui
malheureusement se repose aussi connu
que d'autres personnes à l'automne au
sein de l'histoire du Québec et en
changeant les noms de rue à l'époque qui
voulait dire l'amitié
c'était quand même un geste qui était
neutre qui avait pas un personnage au
centre même de la transformation du nom
car on pensait quand même de Hammer ce
qui avait
été une personne qui avait une
historique très génocidaire donc sa
relation avec les autochtones à l'idée
de l'amitié donc on partait à Montréal
d'un nouveau pas vers nommer des et bien
Joliette on sait avec l'historique de
Joyce jaguan des relations beaucoup plus
tendues
Québec qui sont sur le territoire
ancestral des étiquettes dont la Ville
de Joliette a été construit dessus
donc c'est sûr que cette relation là
doit être appelée à changer mais comme
justement France faisait partie de la
communauté en travaillant justement au
sein des centres d'amitié pour
l'avancement des communautés autochtones
ce territoire là et que justement
c'était aussi un lieu de passage pour
les îlots c'était clairement une chose
appropriée à faire on va voir de plus en
plus chemin des changements non de rue
on va dire que peut-être on va essayer
d'effacer l'histoire du Québec ou du
Canada dépendant d'où on va parce que je
pense aussi au changement du de la place
Johnny mcdownload qui va être qui a été
qui venait tout récemment dans
l'histoire c'est durant 2012 de passer
de la place des Outaouais à la place du
jardin mcdownload pendant justement qui
était le gouvernement de Steven Harper
ça avait coupé 60000 dollars transformés
les pancartes de signalisation mais on
dit maintenant qu'on va retransformer
justement la place dans les médias pour
une où on va choisir un nom ou une voir
une réflexion autour de la
réconciliation le nom va être annoncé
justement en juin probablement autour du
21 juin journée nationale des peuples
autochtones et ensuite on va faire la
transformation pour la journée de la
réconciliation donc la toponymie
présentement je sais qu'il peut y avoir
des contentions sur quels noms choisir
qui on veut honorer quels sont les
personnes qu'on veut mettre de l'avant
et aussi est-ce qu'on est pas en train
d'effacer l'histoire du Québec moi je
dirais plutôt qu'on est en train de la
faire réapparaître parce qu'il faut pas
oublier non plus que derrière
l'effacement toponymique du Québec il y
a eu un choix qui était administratif
qui a été faite au Québec pour effacer
justement les non autochtones et assez
étonnément aussi on oublie que beaucoup
de noms comme Outaouais Québec j'en
pense qui sont justement à la base des
mots autochtones qui ont été franchisés
donc c'est un bon moment pour pouvoir se
mettre à coeur justement de vouloir
honorer des personnes qui sont
importantes pour nous
justement les municipalités avec des
personnes autochtones qui historiquement
ont fait du bien dans la région à la
communauté pour pouvoir les honorer et
justement les faire apparaître dans le
quotidien des Québecois alors je tiens
encore une fois à soulever mon chapeau à
tout le travail que François Burton a
fait dans son vivant et qu'elle continue
justement d'inspirer encore même après
son départ alors je vous souhaite une
belle semaine et je vous dis à la
prochaine